et nous poursuivons
nos travaux de ce jour par une audition
commune
sur les enjeux juridiques nationaux et
internationaux du débat sur la fin de
vie après avoir entendu les
philosophes la semaine passée après un
déplacement en Belgique
et en Suisse et après les
les propos du président de la République
lundi faisant ensuite à la Convention
citoyenne nous poursuivons ce travail
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat qui sera ensuite disponible en
vidéo à la demande
donc cette mission je l'ai déjà dit
s'inscrit dans le cadre des travaux que
nous menons sur la question de la fin de
vie menée par nos rapporteurs Christine
Bonfanti Dossa que je prie d'excuser
mais elle avait un problème de train et
donc elle a dû partir plus tôt beaucoup
de trains annulés Corinne Imbert et
Michel meunier ou en plénière comme ce
fut le cas la semaine passée nous avons
donc le plaisir d'accueillir madame
Bénédicte Boyer peyviaire maître de
conférence en droit privé à l'Université
Paris 8 Vincennes Saint-Denis Madame
Valérie de Pape de comme on dit de pas
mettre de conférences endroit privé à
l'Université Paris 13 Sorbonne Parinor
et Monsieur Julien Jeannet professeur de
droit public à l'Université de
Strasbourg je vous propose donc de
commencer par un propos liminaire
relativement bref
afin de laisser toute leur place aux
échanges qui suivront
voyez bien vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs donc en fait toute la
question est de savoir si aujourd'hui la
fin de vie est dans une situation
satisfaisante notamment du point de vue
législatif alors tout d'abord je crois
que c'est très très important de dire
que la fin de vie à l'hôpital ou encore
à domicile et insuffisante donc au
niveau matériel au niveau humain et
au niveau de l'organisation des hôpitaux
alors pour vous faire une idée en 2019
26 départements ne disposaient pas
d'unités de soins palliatifs et d'au
moins un lit pour 100000 habitants donc
il convient avant tout de prendre en
considération cette situation puisque à
quoi bon faire de multiples lois
successives
si initialement dans la pratique
l'hôpital
la santé de fin de vie les soins
palliatifs
ne marchent pas et ne mettent pas en
application la loi déjà existante
convient-il de changer la loi c'est une
question alors je dirais que
personnellement je n'ai pas à prendre
par à une telle question mais par contre
au regard du droit et au regard de
l'éthique c'est une question qui est
vraiment fondamentale
nous avons l'article L
1110-5 du Code de Santé publique qui dit
que toute personne a le droit d'avoir
une fin digne
accompagnée du meilleur apaisement
apaisement possible de la souffrance
donc vous êtes d'accord on ne peut pas
laisser les personnes souffrir tandis
conditions abominables lorsqu'elles sont
en fin de vie alors si on les juif faire
pourquoi et bien parce qu'il y a des
limites dans la loi
donc jusqu'à présent on a prévu la
sédation profonde et continue pour les
personnes qui étaient en soins
palliatifs et dont la vie est abrégé à
court terme donc vous voyez on a choisi
le législateur à choisir le court terme
or le Comité consultatif national
d'éthique dans son avis 139 montre du
doigt le fait que vous avez des
personnes qui sont en soins palliatifs
qui sont à moyen terme ou à long terme
dans une situation extrêmement difficile
à des situations de gros souffrances
donc on ne peut pas les laisser dans de
telles situations
première question fondamentale est-ce
qu'il conviendra
d'envisager la sédation profonde on en
parle pas beaucoup de cette sédation
profonde vous voyez on parle beaucoup de
l'euthanasie du suicide assister et
aujourd'hui la loi prévoit la sédation
profonde mais à court terme donc la
sédation à moyen terme pourra pourquoi
pas être une situation intermédiaire
donc on pourrait reprendre des
situations enfin les mêmes enfin des
règles analogues mais le problème le
problème dans une telle hypothèse c'est
qu'on a pas assez de recherches sur la
souffrance
la souffrance que peuvent ressentir les
personnes lorsqu'elles sont endormis
donc c'est une question difficile mais
je pense qu'il est important quand même
de l'évoquer autre question
convient-il d'envisager le suicide
assisté c'est-à-dire l'aide à mourir par
une prescription médicale de produits
létal ou encore l'euthanasie donc là
c'est le médecin qui va aussi prescrire
le produit létal et qui va réaliser
l'acte
situation extrêmement complexe qui reste
vraiment difficile à réfléchir et vous
parlementaire vous avez un rôle très
très important à lire pour bien voir un
petit peu cette balance entre les
éléments positifs et les éléments
négatifs alors déjà le tanazi ou le
système et bien il ne faut à mon sens
limité dans la loi dans la suite de la
dans la succession des lois qu'on a eu
jusqu'à là uniquement dans des cas très
très exceptionnel notamment comme je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure lorsque la
loi ne peut pas prendre en considération
le moyen terme ou la le terme dans la
souffrance réfractaire il faut limiter
ça aussi aux soins palliatifs
la question aussi qui viendra se greffer
cela dessus ce sont les risques si on
fait de l'euthanasie si on autorise
l'euthanasie ou encore si on autorise le
suicide assisté
comment va-t-on pouvoir
évaluer
l'autonomie de la volonté c'est très
très important de bien prendre des
mesures dans ce sens il ne faut pas
faire n'importe quoi donc ce sera
d'autant plus important que les
personnes sont atteintes de grandes
fragilités de grandes souffrances donc
l'autonomie de la volonté va poser des
difficultés pour les apprécier nous
avons aussi les risques de
stigmatisation sociale les risques de
stigmatisation professionnelle
et même les risques
d'autostigmatisation c'est à dire que la
personne va se dire je suis en fin de
vie je suis un fardeau je suis un
fardeau pour ma famille et peut-être
même que un jour l'hôpital surtout qu'il
y a pas beaucoup de lit va se dire on
n'a pas de place on a peu de on n'a pas
de place on a peu de
lit en soi palliatifs c'est ce qui
existe déjà dans la réalité
bon peut-être qu'on va plus aller dans
le soin dans le dans l'euthanasie
la question qui se pose c'est la
proportionnalité la proportionnalité
c'est-à-dire entre l'apaisement qu'on
peut apporter aux personnes
et entre les risques qui peuvent exister
pour protéger la personne à chaque fois
vous voyez la finalité c'est la
protection des individus dans une très
grande vulnérabilité
alors bien sûr on a pour pouvoir évaluer
cette proportionnalité mes collègues
vont pouvoir développer davantage après
tous les grands principes principes de
dignité principe de liberté principe
d'égalité principe de solidarité
l'importe aussi de réfléchir c'est la
situation des professionnels de santé
professionnelle de santé qui ont été
largement éprouvés déjà par rapport à la
situation de l'hôpital mais aussi par
rapport au sermon d'Hippocrate ils ont
toujours été habitués à soigner la
personne donc pour eux c'est difficile
de pouvoir donner la mort par rapport à
l'euthanasie ou encore par rapport
au suicide assisté donc je crois qu'il
faut aller dans le sens de la clause de
conscience qui est aussi un moyen de
leur laisser la liberté de choisir ou
pas alors après il y a une garantie
c'est que s'il y a une clause de
conscience c'est de renvoyer la personne
vers une autre un autre professionnel de
santé donc il y a cette possibilité là
mais on pourrait aussi prévoir une autre
possibilité créer
5 ou 6 unités dans toute la France qui
en charge les personnes atteintes de
sédation profonde et enfin oui atteint
de pardon qui souhaiterait faire de
l'euthanasie et en fait ça serait des
services complètement dédiés et ça
serait un déchargera le poids des
professionnels de santé donc rapidement
il convient aussi de prévoir des
services très très spécifiques pour la
prise en charge des personnes il
convient aussi de prévoir des
financements dédiés aussi bien dans les
établissements que par rapport à la
tarification adaptée
concernant les 10 Act
et pour terminer
je vais insister sur ce point on en
parle pas du tout c'est l'accessibilité
du droit
aujourd'hui vous avez une partie et des
dispositions légales qui sont
concentrées dans la partie législative
du code de la santé publique et vous
avez beaucoup beaucoup de dispositions
qui sont dans le dans le code enfin
toujours dans le code de la santé
publique mais dans le code de
déontologie médicale le code de
déontologie médiale de déontologie
médicale c'est un outil pour les
médecins
mais les personnes de la société ne vont
pas forcément lire le code de
déontologie médicale alors que toutes il
y a vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
dispositions qui sont dans ce code de
déontologie médicale et qu'on ne
retrouve pas dans la partie
réglementaire donc je crois qu'il sera
important à la fois de restructurer
le droit de la fin de vie c'est à dire
mettre tout en dans une partie
spécifique du code de la santé publique
pour que les gens puissent ouvrir le
code et voir tout ce qui existe et
rapatrier certaines lignes dispositions
qui sont dans le cas de déontologie
médicale dans la partie réglementaire
pour que ça soit accessible à tous et
bien sûr dans le code de déontologie
médicale les médecins prévoient toujours
leur propre disposition pour prendre en
charge la fonction voilà je vous
remercie merci Madame à vous de
pas merci madame la Présidente
mesdames les sénatrices monsieur les
sénateurs je voudrais liminairement vous
dire que je vais me permettre de parler
du ressenti des médecins parce que je
travaille de façon assez étroite avec
eux voilà je pense qu'un juriste seul
dans ces questions est impuissant qu'il
faut de l'humidité quand on fait du
droit face aux professionnels donc c'est
pour ça que je me permettrai de parler
de leur ressenti alors parmi les
questions qui se posent pour entrer dans
le vif du sujet bien il faut distinguer
la situation de la personne dont le
pronostic vital est engagé à court terme
très court terme et celle dont le
pronostic vital est engagé par la
maladie mais à plus long terme
le droit actuel répond aux situations
d'extrême fan de vie en autorisant la
sédation profonde et continue ce type de
sédation qui est un des apports majeurs
de la loi de 2016 dans la loi de 2016 ce
type de sédation a été conçu je crois
qu'il faut bien l'avoir en tête comme
une mesure de soulagement de lutte
contre la souffrance pas un moyen de
mettre fin à la vie et en ce sens cette
sédation ne contrevient pas au
sermanthippocrate ce qu'il a rendu
beaucoup plus facile enfin oui plus aisé
à accepter pour les médecins
et pourtant les médecins apparaissent
réticents certains médecins dans
certains cas mais assez fréquents
apparaissent réticents face à cette
sédation parce qu'il s'interroge il
s'interroge à plusieurs titres que vit
et prouve le patient certes il est
endormi mais que vit qui éprouvent-ils
à quel niveau ta conscience est-il rendu
et aussi et surtout parce que ces
médecins se préoccupent des tiques quel
sens donner à ce temps à ce temps de
sommeil de sommeil artificiel du point
de vue du patient et aussi parce que la
question
est à mon avis secondaire mais
importante que vit la famille qui
parfois voit le corps donné des marques
de souffrance
or ce temps est très variable lorsque ce
type de sédation est appliqué un patient
pour lequel un prélèvement d'organes de
type masse riche 3 c'est-à-dire sur
coeur arrêté est envisagé et bien les
médecins arrêtent leur respirateur et le
délai le délai qui sépare l'arrêt tu es
suppliance vitale du constat de décès
par arrêt cardiaque et d'environ 15
minutes
Vincent Lambert monsieur Vincent Lambert
patient neurosérébral est resté c'est
daté neuf jours avant de décéder 9 jours
qui ont été puisque l'affaire était
malheureusement médiatisée
on sait que ces journées ont été très
difficiles à vivre pour les proches
alors on voit ici à quel temps le point
de la sédation peut varier or raccourcir
le temps de la sédation lorsqu'elle se
prolonge implique évidemment d'injecter
au patients des doses létales ce que ça
fait les médecins mais alors il ne
s'agit plus d'une sédation comme elle
est entendue par la loi puisque le
dosage aura pour but d'abréger la vie
alors je suis bien consciente de poser
le problème sans y apporter de solution
mais bon nous comptons
au-delà de ces questions la sédation
profonde et continue ne peut répondre
aux situations dans lesquelles le
pronostic vital n'est pas engagé à court
terme parce qu'alors d'abord elle serait
longue et signe de souffrance seraient
apparent le temps de l'inconnu
s'éterniserait et la personne ne
décéderait pas des causes de sa maladie
elle déciderait d'infections multiples
aussi faut-il vous faut-il aborder la
question aussi difficile soit elle d'une
assistance au suicide voire d'une
euthanasie notre président très
récemment a fait savoir souhaiter les
laboration d'un modèle français de fin
de vie
il me semble que cette expression
souligne toute la difficulté de la
transcription juridique d'un droit à
l'aide actif à mourir il va falloir le
transcrire mais ce sera une tâche
particulièrement difficile cette
expression à mon sens signifie que la
loi ne peut simplement acter la volonté
des Français quant à l'ouverture d'un
droit à une étape active à une
adaptative à mourir
elle doit lactée dans le respect des
valeurs essentielles d'humanité de
solidarité d'accompagnement des plus
vulnérables qui sont les nôtres
et en ce sens la loi sur la fin de vie
doit d'abord apporter des propositions
de vie en réponse au crainte que les
Français expriment d'être abandonnés en
situation de souffrance
alors de ce point de vue les deux
questions évidemment de l'offre de soins
palliatifs et d'un droit à choisir le
moment de son décès sont liés elles sont
différentes mais elles sont liées dans
le temps l'insuffisance des soins
palliatifs fausse le débat parce que
dans le paysage désolé désolant des
soins de vie l'aide à mourir ne devra
jamais devenir un moyen d'éviter
l'agonie
si une procédure d'assistance à une mort
anticipée quelle qu'en soit
l'appellation devait être légalement
institué elle ne devrait pouvoir être
mise en application sans que l'ensemble
des soins médicaux possibles
techniquement possible envisageable en
état des possibilités scientifiques
étaient préalablement proposé au
patients des soins de qualité et des
quand je dis de qualité
une qualité temporelle c'est-à-dire des
soins qui puissent être dispensés le
temps nécessaire parce que s'il en est
autrement l'Adaptive à mourir
représentera une alternative par défaut
à des soins de fin de vie de qualité
alors la question de l'aide active ne
peut se poser qu'en cas d'impuissance de
la médecine à calmer la souffrance
les médecins expliquent qu'une fois la
douleur y compris psychique apaisé la
demande de mort devient exceptionnelle
elle existe mais elle devient
exceptionnelle
dès lors que le maintien de cette
demande apparaît en pratique
exceptionnelle
dès lors que des soins palliatifs sont
dispensés n'est-ce pas uniquement ces
cas exceptionnels que doit relayer la
loi pardon en permettant l'aide au
suicides n'ont pas comme un droit
universel j'ai trouvé cette expression
dans le rapport des citoyens elle m'a un
petit peu voilà mais un petit peu marqué
donc non comme un droit universel
mentionné dans le rapport de la
convention citoyenne mais comme un
ultime recours
la décision relèvera du Parlement garant
de la souveraineté nationale et du fait
majoritaire car la question est
sociétale néanmoins comparé à d'autres
elle se distingue elle se distingue
lorsqu'elle implique de façon majeure le
médecin c'est pourquoi à consensus doit
être trouvé avec le corps médical
la clause de conscience permet aux
médecins de ne pas pratiquer tel ou tel
acte en l'espèce il s'agirait de l'acte
létal mais le médecin est tenu de
contacter à mes seins qui accepteraient
de le faire
de tout temps des médecins ont t'aider
des malades à mourir par compassion pour
ne pas les abandonner dans le cadre d'un
colloque singulier aussi les médecins
qui accepteront de pratiquer l'acte
létal l'accepteront certainement pour
leur patient dans la volonté
d'accompagner leur patient jusqu'au bout
de la route jusqu'au terme de leur vie
mais il est très peu probable qu'ils
acceptent de prendre en charge un
patient dans ce seul objectif devenir
des sortes de docteur tanator si vous
permettez l'expression
donc une des difficultés les principales
de légiférer est ici que la loi va
devoir se frayer un chemin vers la
volonté du patient sans entraver le
colloque singulier entre le patient et
son médecin ce colloque doit être
maintenu ne peut être empêché par un
droit qui serait à droite créance à
demander à exiger l'euthanasie ou le
suicide assisté à droite trop affirmé
mais très ta mal ce colloque singulier
tellement importante tellement de
nécessaire aux patients c'est pourquoi
plutôt que de parler des critères de
minutie qu'on leur comme l’ont fait
beaucoup de nos pays voisins peut-être
faut-il se concentrer sur le moyen
d'assurer au patients qu'il sera entendu
tout en protégeant un espace d'autonomie
professionnelle qui permettra de
respecter la singularité inhérente à
chaque situation une loi ne répondra
jamais à toutes les situations
et une telle démarche n'empêche pas une
intervention collégiale afin que le
médecin ne porte pas seul la décision
qu'on ne puisse ressentir une toute
puissance du médecin et puis aussi pour
permettre un autre regard un regard
collégial sur la situation du patient
quoi qu'il en soit le droit et ses
limites devront être suffisamment
solides pour résister à leur dépassement
tout en permettant un espace d'autonomie
professionnelle qui je me permets
d'assister respecte la singularité
inhérente à chaque situation
alors dans notre paysage actuel de la
santé publique les usagers du système de
santé ont peur ils craignent d'être race
ils ont besoin d'être rassurés ils
doivent être rassurés ils doivent savoir
qu'ils seront pris en charge de la
meilleure façon qui puisse être et que
si cette prise en charge ne peut calmer
leur souffrance une ultime solution leur
sera apportée mais les usagers
sont et sont d'abord sans doute des
citoyens des citoyens auxquels les
pouvoirs publics doivent offrir une
société qui privilégie la vie en
apportant aide attention au plus
vulnérables en prodiquant les soins le
plus longtemps et le plus
raisonnablement possible en accompagnant
ensuite dignement le décès en dernier
recours et je crois pouvoir dire
qu'on peut en tant qu'usager pour
soi-même souhaiter savoir qu'on sera
entendu le jour où on décide de dire
stop au traitement sans pour autant en
tant que citoyen souhaiter vivre dans
une société qui ouvrirait trop largement
la possibilité d'une fin de vie merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs c'est toujours
un plaisir pour universitaire d'être
invité à présenter le fruit de ses
recherches dans l'espoir de pouvoir
contribuer à éclairer la représentation
nationale m'avait demandé de venir vous
éclairer sur le cadre juridique de la
fin de vie dans différents pays
professeurs de droit professionnel je
m'intéresserai surtout à des principes
constitutionnels à des décisions rendues
par des juridictions constitutionnelles
et au contexte dans lequel certaines
lois ont été élaborées dans d'autres
pays conduisant à dépénaliser à
autoriser ou à organiser non une aide
active à mourir sous certaines
conditions et je partirai à cet égard
d'une tension qui traverse de nombreuses
démocraties contemporaines d'un côté la
provocation de sa propre mort est un
acte d'autodétermination personnelle qui
prend la forme classique dans sa
brutalité même du suicide d'un autre
côté c'est un acte qui intéresse la
société entière en tant quicontre car le
cours normal des choses et c'est à la
rencontre de ces deux tendances que
différents parlements différents juges
constitutionnels on choisit de faire
évoluer leurs droits dans le sens d'un
plus grand accompagnement des candidats
au trépas
encore faut-il préciser ce dont il est
question l'aide à mourir peut renvoyer à
quatre actions distinctes qui soulèvent
des questions différentes du point de
vue du droit dans l'ordre de la
préparation de la mort on peut
distinguer l'interruption des
traitements les médecins se contentent
de laisser la mort survenir en son temps
en arrêtant de soigner et les soins
palliatifs qui conduisent à pour les
médecins à prodiguer des soins destinés
à soulager la souffrance du patient
notamment dans le cadre d'une sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès à
l'inverse dans l'ordre du déclenchement
de la mort qui soulève des questions
juridiques tout à fait distinctes
forment plus active d'aide à mourir on
distingue habituellement l'assistance au
suicide comme la rappeler l'une de mes
collègues avant moi on accompagne le
patient qui commet infini l'axe de
mortifère contrairement à l'euthanasie
stricto-sensue qui veut que l'acte
mortifère délibéré soit commis par un
auxiliaire parfois situation parfois
nécessaire pour les plus malades qui ne
pourraient pas se suicider eux-mêmes
distinction
une décisive en droit mais qui en
pratique est assez fine on l'imagine et
ça soulève évidemment des questions en
la matière il est assez courant de
d'évoquer certains de nos voisins
certains des pays qui sont autour de
nous pour différentes raisons tout
d'abord parce que certains d'entre eux
ont privilégié des législations
particulièrement libérales en la matière
d'autre part parce que des Français
anonymes ou célèbres ont décidé d'aller
finir leur jour dans ces pays et enfin
parce que ces pays sont parfois invoqués
mis en avant comme une forme
d'épouvantail argumentatif en les
présentant non sans caricature comme des
lieux où l'on pourrait orchestrer sa
mort en cas de simples spleen passagers
et où on pourrait accéder à des produits
locaux les taux pardon de façon tout à
fait facile je passerai rapidement la
Suisse évidemment qui dès 1941 a prévu
que l'assistance au suicide dont le
mobile est altruiste n'était plus
réprimés les Pays-Bas bien sûr qui ont
des pénalisés l'assistance au suicide et
le tanazi en 2001 sous certaines
conditions la demande répétée du malade
lorsqu'il peut l'exprimer le caractère
incurable de sa maladie la vie pris
auprès d'autres médecins et le
signalement de la mort aux autorités
quant à la Belgique où je comprends que
certains membres de sa commission se
sont rendus récemment elle a dépénalisé
l'euthanasie active en 2002 sous
certaines conditions majorité du patient
ce qui a été étendu en 2014 au mineur
dans des circonstances qui soulèvent des
questions formulation de demande
volontaire réfléchie et répétées
situation médicale
issue pardon et patient qui fait état
d'une souffrance psychique ou
psychologique constante quant aux autres
États le Luxembourg en 2009 pour
l'assistance suicide et l'euthanasie
l'Espagne en 95 pour l'assistance au
suicide et en 2021 pour l'euthanasie et
plus loin de nous la Nouvelle-Zélande
situation intéressante car le choix a
été fait de recourir au référendum pour
légaliser l'euthanasie en 2020 ce sont
des situations que l'on invoque aussi
régulièrement alors quel est le rôle
joué plus particulièrement par les juges
constitutionnels parce que c'est la
question qui m'a été posée dans
l'évolution de ces législations sur la
fin de vie
première remarque les juges de manière
générale s'attachent on peut penser que
c'est le cas des individus qui composent
ces juridictions c'est en tout cas un
argument qui est volontiers mis en avant
à se montrer en retrait à laisser les
Parlement être les forums pertinents
pour trancher ces questions épineuses
deuxième observation il arrive néanmoins
que les jeux soient plus actifs comme
nous le verrons qu'il conduisent à
provoquer en quelque sorte des
législations dans des conditions qui
soulèvent un certain nombre de questions
autre observation les juges sont souvent
sollicités les juges constitutionnels en
particulier en effet dans certains pays
on peut noter qu'il est parfois plus
facile pour les personnes qui défendent
la mise en place d'une aide active à
mourir d'accéder au prétoire de juge
constitutionnel que de pousser les
parlementaires à se saisir eux-mêmes de
la question ainsi s'explique le nombre
important de décisions rendues à ce
sujet par différentes juridictions
constitutionnelles mais aussi par des
organes
supranationaux de protection des droits
de l'homme à la star de la secours
européenne droit de l'homme dont on
vient de parler et notamment cette
décision mortier contre Belgique dont
chers collègues vous venez de parler qui
est particulièrement important dans la
mesure où la Cour européenne des droits
de l'homme dans ce cadre-là affirmé
qu'une loi
autorisant le tanazine méconnaissait pas
de ce simple fait le droit à la vie
garantie par l'article 2 de la
Convention tout en refusant l'existence
d'un droit à mourir et en laissant comme
vous l'avez dit aux États une large
marge d'appréciation
alors les relations entre les juges
constitutionnels et les parlements quand
on rentre un peu plus dans le détail
sont assez diverses et il est possible
de les ramener à 4 grandes
configurations première configuration le
cas dans lequel une réforme
parlementaire et consolider par une
juridiction constitutionnelle le cas
d'école en l'occurrence et le cas belge
le Parlement en 2002 comme je l'ai dit à
autoriser l'euthanasie l'a ouvert aux
mineurs en 2014 et le 29 octobre 2015 la
Cour constitutionnelle a inféré du droit
au respect de la vie privée le droit de
décider de mettre fin à sa vie pour
éviter une fin de vie indigne et pénible
deuxième cas de figure le cas dans
lequel une réforme parlementaire est
neutralisée par une juridiction
constitutionnelle et là c'est le cas qui
nous est donné par le Portugal ou en
2021 le Parlement à dépénalisé à la fois
l'assistance au suicide et le thanazi
sous conditions dans un cadre médical
avant que le Président de la République
opposait à la réforme conservateur si
oppose en saisissant le Tribunal
constitutionnel qui a déclaré la loi
inconstitutionnelle au nom du fait que
cette loi comportait des catégories
juridiques trop vagues notamment en ce
qui concernait la question des
souffrances le Parlement a adopté une
nouvelle loi qui a subi un veto
présidentiel en novembre 2021 et une
nouvelle loi est encore en discussion on
a donc un jeu de d'aller-retour de
ping-pong entre le Parlement d'un côté
le Tribunal constitutionnel et le
président de l'autre qui n'est pas
terminé troisième configuration la
configuration dans laquelle il y a une
incitation juridictionnelle qui conduit
à une réforme parlementaire
sur ce point trois situations distinctes
méritent d'être distinguées tout d'abord
la manière forte qui nous est montrée
par le Tribunal constitutionnel fédéral
allemand qui le 26 février 2020 alors
qu'il n'existait pas de loi autorisant
l'aide actif à mourir à censurer une loi
qui prohibait l'assistance aux suicide
dans un cadre professionnel en tirant du
principe de dignité de la personne
humaine écrit dans la Constitution dont
il avait déjà inféré un principe un
droit au libre épanouissement de sa
personnalité un droit de choisir sa mort
et c'est ça la nouveauté de la décision
qui n'est pas limitée aux maladies
graves ou incurables et donc là on a un
tribunal constitutionnel qui consacre un
principe constitutionnel de droits de
choisir sa mort et qui conduit le
législateur à essayer de suivre ce
principe éventuellement en adoptant mais
ils sont en train de travailler sur ce
point une loi en la matière de manière
plus détournée il arrive que des juges
constitutionnels se fondent sur des
réserves d'interprétation pour pousser
le Parlement alors qu'est-ce qu'on
appelle une réserve interprétation pour
mémoire dans le cadre en tout cas du
Conseil constitutionnel français c'est
le cas dans lequel une juridiction
constitutionnelle déclare une loi
conforme à la Constitution en précisant
que cette déclaration de
constitutionnalité et sous réserve du
fait que telle ou tel article est
interprété de tel ou telle manière on
est donc dans un cas où le juge
constitutionnel qui d'habitude pour
reprendre une distinction du Doyen Vedel
n'utilise que la gomme peut
marginalement utiliser le crayon en
essayant en affirmant le fait que la loi
doit être légèrement réécrite dans tel
ou telle direction en l'occurrence c'est
ce qui s'est passé en Colombie ou en
1997 la Cour constitutionnelle a créé
une cause d'irresponsabilité pénale en
matière de tanazie tout en invitant le
Parlement à légiférer sur la question en
2000 le Parlement a réagi à l'inverse en
prohibant de façon générale l'euthanasie
en 2015 le ministre de la Santé à lui
adopté un acte qui légalisait en
pratique l'euthanasie contre la loi et
en 20 la Cour a déclaré que la loi
pénale prohibant l'euthanasie était
conforme à la Constitution sous réserve
qu'on souhaite exclu l'acte réalisé avec
le consentement du malade quel que soit
l'état d'avancement de la maladie et
tout en invitant encore une fois le
Parlement à légiférer pour mieux
protéger le droit de mourir dans la
dignité enfin la manière encore plus
douce d'agir consiste à moduler dans le
temps les effets d'une décision
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire des
juridictions constitutionnelles on la
possibilité de dire je déclare telle loi
contraire à la Constitution mais je
repousse dans le temps les effets de ma
décision en particulier pour laisser au
Parlement le soin de légiférer dans
l'intervalle en l'occurrence c'est le
choix qui a été privilégié au Canada ou
en 2015 la Cour suprême a jugé que la
prohibition pénale de l'aide à mourir
méconnaissait le droit à la vie à la
liberté et à la sécurité des personnes
telles qu'il est garantie par l'article
7 de la Charte canadienne des droits et
libertés en tant qu'elles prive de cette
aide certaines catégorie de malades la
Cour a repoussé d'un an puis de quatre
mois les effets de sa décision et entre
temps le Parlement a adopté une loi se
conformant à la décision de la Cour
enfin la quatrième configuration que
l'on observe et celle dans laquelle la
réforme prode de la juridiction
elle-même en raison d'une inertie
prolongée du Parlement alors même que du
temps lui avait été laissé pour aller
dans cette direction c'est la situation
qui nous est donnée par la Cour c'est
l'exemple qui nous est donné par la Cour
constitutionnelle italienne dans toute
une saga qui a conduit à la cour à
rendre plusieurs décisions dans
l'affaire Marco capato alors en quelques
mots Marco capato était un ancien
parlementaire européen activiste qui a
volontairement été accompagnée un DJ qui
est très connu qui avait subi un
accident de voiture très grave ensuite
pour y bénéficier d'une assistance au
suicide il est revenu en Italie il est
allé voir les carabineries en disant
voilà arrêtez moi je viens de commettre
une infraction au regard du code pénal
italien être provoquer un grand débat
sur l'aide à mourir et en l'occurrence à
l'occasion de son procès pénal a été
soulevé la question de la
constitutionnalité de la loi pénale qui
fondait les poursuites à son encontre et
dans ce cadre-là la Cour
constitutionnelle en 2018 a rendu une
première ordonnance en principe
provisoire mais qui en réalité on va le
voir fixait déjà un certain nombre de
choses pour dire que en gros
il fallait dans le débat entre liberté
de s'autodéterminer d'un côté et
protection de la vie humaine de l'autre
reconnaître que il y avait des causes
d'irresponsabilité pénales qui devait
être reconnues dans le creux de la loi
pénale interdisant de manière générale
le suicide assister ou plutôt
l'assistance au suicide lorsque la
pathologie est incurable que les
souffrances ont intolérables que le
maintien en vie est artificiel et que la
capacité de prendre des décisions libres
et conscientes et néanmoins maintenues
dans ce cas de figure nous dit la Cour
constitutionnelle il convient de créer
une cause d'irresponsabilité pénale mais
je ne change pas cette question moi-même
nous dit le juge je repousse d'un an non
pas les effets de ma décision mais la
décision elle-même j'affirme que cette
décision n'est que provisoire et d'ici
un an si le Parlement a légiféré nous
verrons bien le Parlement un an plus
tard ne lui faire pas et un an plus tard
en 2019 la cour rend une décision
définitive constatant l'inertie
prolongée du législateur et notant que
la loi pénale est inconstitutionnel en
tant qu'elles ne prévoit pas une
exception dans le cas de figure qui
avait été identifié un an plus tôt
je passe rapidement sur le fait que en
2022 troisième décision dans la saga
kapato le même kapato avait sollicité un
référendum abrogatif d'initiative
populaire qui est une procédure qui
permet de demander l'abrogation d'une
disposition législative par référendum
dans ce cadre la cour opère un contrôle
et la Cour a bloqué en l'occurrence un
tel référendum qui portait non plus sur
le suicide assisté l'assistant se
suicide pardon mais sur l'euthanasie en
somme la cour italienne dans ce cas
précis a écrit la loi sur l'assistance
au suicide en fait du fait du de
l'inertie certes du Parlement elle a
évité que la loi évolue en matière
d'euthanasie c'est un cas intéressant où
le cours qu'on ou une cour
constitutionnelle à faire en
l'occurrence cavalier seul voilà pour
mon parcours je j'ai d'éventuelles
éléments de réflexion sur le Conseil
constitutionnel mais peut-être qu'on va
garder ça pour d'éventuelles questions
alors
ensuite
Michel meunier vous les rapporteurs
un petit peu sur la place de cette
audition aujourd'hui
en commission puisque nous sommes qu'il
y a un travail qui est en cours en tout
cas sur la mission une mission sur les
soins palliatifs
heureusement j'ai pas pu y participer
mais
je reviendrai pas sur le j'allais dire
sur le fond du problème quel est le
problème est très long complexe on a eu
encore donc pas plus tard que lundi la
vie de cette commission avec 150
personnes qui ont été tirées au sort qui
a été rendus lundi après-midi ou lundi
matin je sais plus faire en tout cas
c'était lundi
je veux pas revenir sur le fond parce
que on ouvrirait un débat
que j'espère en aura parce que j'espère
bien qu'on aura un texte
législatif qui fera avancer ce sujet et
qui est extrêmement complexe moi je
voulais juste
m'élever contre une phrase que vous avez
dit de madame qui m'a vraiment fait
sursauter ça s'est entendu d'ailleurs
et que je trouve extrêmement choquante
quand vous dites
parce qu'il manque de place à l'hôpital
il faudrait on court un risque que les
soignants
décident j'allais dire de tuer des gens
simplement pour libérer des places c'est
intolérable pour moi et je pense que
pour beaucoup d'autres ici c'est
vraiment une insulte à la profession
médicale et aux professions de santé que
je ne peux pas tolérer donc je tenais à
vous le dire
alors en fait je n'ai absolument pas
souhaité dire une telle une telle chose
je dis simplement que lorsque les lits
sont limitées en soins palliatifs
il y a quand même il y a quand même à
répondre voilà les gens sont dans leur
lit
l'hôpital fonctionne à sa manière il va
y avoir de nouveau de nouvelles
personnes qui vont arriver
que faire et regarder ce qui s'est passé
pendant la covid pendant la covid il y a
eu aussi
des situations intolérables je trouve
que ce sont des situations intolérables
et en fait même si on ne peut pas les
supporter elles existent et je crois que
c'est indispensable de prendre en
considération ces situations pour que le
législateur mais aussi pour que l'État
intervienne pour mettre à disposition
tous les moyens qu'il faut pour la fin
de vie mais connais pas ces deux places
en soins palliatifs on en est tous
d'accord mais que vous puissiez de dire
que un médecin en conscience va choisir
monsieur X ou Madame Y c'est pas
possible
qu'il faut gérer mais il faut gérer un
service il faut gérer une unité
et voilà donc il y a pas le choix en
fait
concernant la première marque de Milian
pour mes rôles je rappelle que la
mission confiée à
Christine bonfanty Corinne Imbert et
Michel Meunier et la suite de leur
mission qu'elles avaient fait sur les
soins palliatifs mais qu'elle est
maintenant intitulée mission sur la fin
de vie
je voulais rappeler que on assimile
souvent le texte les textes qui vont
venir il y aura un texte au président de
la République Lady
quel sera-t-il ça on le verra
pour l'instant
souvent on présente en disant la loi
leonétique laisse et méconnue il y a
passé directives anticipées il y a pas
assez de l'aide sur un palliatifs même
si on peut faire du palliatif à domicile
et je pense qu'il faut vraiment aussi
qu'on axe vers là
on présente un peu souvent la loi à
venir comme la suite de la loi
leonétique classe pour moi c'est
totalement différent la loi lune dit
classe c'est une loi sur des une
citation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès en cas de de mort imminente à
court terme pour soulager les
souffrances parce que beaucoup de gens
souhaitent certes mauvais souhaitent
surtout le non acharnement thérapeutique
et pouvoir avoir une mort apaisée et
c'est souvent aussi le souhait de leur
famille là on passe sur un autre sur les
différents on va passer sur après chacun
le droit d'avoir son avis et de savoir
ce sur quoi on s'orient parce qu'il y a
des différences entre les pays mais je
n'aime pas bien qu'on assimile et je
pense que Jean Le n'était-il ne l'aime
pas beaucoup d'ailleurs qu'on assimile
un texte à venir sur la suite de sa loi
non c'est une loi différente c'est
comment on répond à une mort choisie par
nos citoyens comment on y répond est-ce
qu'on y répond ou non est-ce qu'on y
répond pas une assistance au suicide ou
est-ce qu'on va jusqu'en effet
l'euthanasie tel qu'elle est pratiquée
ou c'est vraiment entre le médecin et le
patient que cela se joue mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit qu'on est bien ça
en tête parce que sinon on mélange un
peu tout et
même si je comprends la maladresse qui a
eu mais c'est vrai que il faudrait pas
que parce qu'il y a pas de soins
palliatifs non c'est différent c'est une
mort choisie un citoyen peut exprimer un
choix de de mort ou de fin de vie mais
c'est un texte à mes yeux totalement
différent sur lequel on devra discuter
Michel meunier
merci madame la Présidente d'avoir remis
ce contexte
donc je suis une des co-rapporteurs avec
Christine beaufantili de ça et Corinne
Imbert sur cette question et je trouve
que cette audition de ce matin vient
bien complété complexifier même les
auditions nombreuses que nous menons
depuis le début si on veut bien prendre
en compte le travail précédent autour
des soins palliatifs
et j'avoue que
la semaine dernière on nous avions une
table ronde de philosophe il y en a un
qui a dit que cette one pourrait pas
être consensuelle ça je le pense
franchement il y aura des éléments de
consensualité on en connaît entre nous
même ici dans cette commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat et puis il y
en aura qui seront plus clivantes et
après ce sera aux politiques de prendre
la responsabilité de le faire moi je
veux bien parce que je vous ai entendu
en tout cas merci mesdames de nous avoir
redonné aussi le sens de l'éthique dans
le droit et je suis très sensible avec
ces valeurs
à la fois de non malfaisance de
bienfaits bienveillance et de
l'autonomie de la du patient et c'est
vraiment de ça dont il s'agit moi je
voulais vous questionner monsieur Julien
Jeannet parce que vous avez une
spécificité qui est intéressante et moi
quand on est allé avec la présidente et
mes collègues en Belgique j'ai été
frappé sur une question qui n'est pas
une question de sémantique je pense
parce que les Belges ils ont pas
légalisé l'euthanasie ils ont dépénalisé
l'euthanasie et sur leur brochure c'est
bien inscrit loi dépénalisant
l'euthanasie alors je suis pas du tout
juriste de formation et je voudrais bien
avoir la la perception l'analyse de ce
que vous faites qu'est-ce que quel est
cette grande différence entre voilà les
termes et par de la les actes
oui merci à la présidente merci mesdames
merci Monsieur pour pour vos
interventions juste en complément dire à
emiliane qu'on a voulu associer
l'ensemble des commissaires de façon on
était toutes les trois d'accord pour
ouvrir à l'ensemble des commissaires ces
auditions tout en complément des
auditions évidemment que nous faisons en
rapporteur
j'ai trois quatre questions mais très
courte et avec peut-être des réponses
très courtes aussi parce que sinon on va
encore y passer beaucoup de temps ou
sinon vous me répondrez si vous voulez
peut-être par écrit sur si vous voulez
dans la formulation plus longue
en tant que juriste l'acte de thanasie
est-il à soin
quel est votre définition de la mort
naturelle ou d'une mort naturelle
sur ça que vous pouvez disserter
certainement trop longuement donc mais
juste comme ça je fais peur de mes
questions mes questions sont courtes les
réponses sont certainement longues mais
donc voilà en quelques mots puis tout le
monde aura accès au compte-rendu de la
commission donc on pourra on fera il y
aura un rapport où tout ça sera vraiment
sionner si vous me fait des réponses
écrites
quelles conséquence juridique que
peuvent engendrer demain liberté de
demander sa mort et dignité et j'allais
même rajouter égalité puisque vous avez
évoqué l'égalité
et
quel quel risque de pente glissante
voilà je vais sûrement d'autres
questions mais je vais me tenir assez
quatre questions très courtes vous le
reconnaîtrez
alors voilà je vais me lancer de façon
rapide mais je n'ai pas toutes les
réponses alors le tanasie
bon est un acte qui consiste à injecter
d'une façon quelconque un produit létale
afin que la personne décède
évidemment c'est pas un soin dans le
sens où c'est pas une mesure de confort
c'est pour ça je pense que
que la réponse est totalement subjective
en fonction des personnes qui répondront
bien sûr c'est pas un soin si simplement
la dernière solution la façon d'arrêter
des souffrances comme parfait pas
arrêter lorsqu'une personne est
condamnée c'est pas soit ça ne procure
pas un confort quelconque
c'est une façon d'arrêter les
souffrances
alors ensuite une mort naturelle dans
votre dans le contexte dans lequel nous
sommes je pense que c'est une mort qui
s'oppose à la mort provoquée par une
substance injectée dans cet objectif
ce que je continue peut-être vous allez
répondre à la suite naturelle justement
en Belgique je crois qu'ils ont la
personne décédée est considérée
décédément naturel ça veut d'ailleurs un
peu été le cas lorsqu'on avait examiné
la proposition de loi de Marie-Pierre de
la Gontrie que rapportait Michel meunier
il y avait cette notions qui
apparaît compliquées parce que une mort
naturelle qui est digne après un coup de
tringle c'est quand même compliqué
intellectuellement à envisager mais sur
le plan juridique ça tient ça pour moi
non
parce que à ce moment là qu'est-ce
qu'une mort non naturelle voilà pour moi
une mort naturelle c'est l'achèvement de
la vie lorsque le corps
l'organisme cesse de fonctionner
lorsqu'on injecte une un produit afin
qu'il cesse de fonctionner
voilà maintenant je pense que les
philosophes répondraient peut-être mieux
que nous en tout cas que moi sur la
notion de nature mais non pour moi c'est
pas une mort naturelle
en fait
le ment naturel je pense pour éviter des
poursuites donc la personne qui a fait
l'injection ne soit pas possible mais
vous allez peut-être mais vous continuez
sur vos réponses
la troisième était les conséquences
juridiques de la demande de mort
vis-à-vis de la dignité je crois
alors oui concernant la dignité bon je
pense pas que l'idée soit de se lancer
dans dans un débat sur la dignité on va
simplement dire que la dignité peut-être
défini de façon rapide comme notre égal
appartenance à l'humanité et je crois
que cette notion alors dans un rapport
que j'ai coordonné que je vous ai
communiqué d'ailleurs cet été on a
abandonné parmi les arguments qu'on
recensés la dignité tout simplement
parce que là la façon
de voir le respect de la dignité selon
qu'on permet l'acte létal ou non et
totalement subjectif voilà maintenant il
est certain qu'il est
il pourrait y avoir mais j'ai pas
d'inquiétude ça n'arrivera pas ça
n'arrivera pas des cas dans lesquels la
dignité ne soit pas respectée mais je
pense que c'est pas notre débat bien sûr
que la dignité sera respectée simplement
chacun d'entre vous aura peut-être une
notion différente du respect de cette
dignité parce que tout le monde reste
digne jusqu'à la fin de séjour c'est
pour ça que j'aime pas beaucoup
l'expression de mourir dans la dignité
un être humain reste digne parce que la
dignité est un attribut tout ça tout
simplement de l'humanité simplement
toute la question est de respecter au
mieux cette dignité et c'est là où je
pense qu'il n'y a pas de de réponse
objective en tout cas trancher
et le risque est alors on appelle ça oui
d'une façon juridique parce que je
prends exemple sur ce qui s'est passé et
notamment la où était au Bauer c'est en
nous
je crois qu'on a tous été marqué par cet
article de Théo Bauer ce qui est certain
c'est que de toute façon la loi de
répondra pas à toutes les demandes à
toutes les situations c'est ce que vous
disez le consensus total n'existe pas
donc certaines personnes se verront
refuser l'éventuel droite tel qu'il sera
défini et ces personnes
pourront défendre leur position
notamment vis-à-vis des juridictions en
invoquant une stigmatisation ou une
inégalité des droits et c'est là où on
risque avec une logique juridique
mais qui détendent ce que vous aurez
décidé parce que certaines personnes qui
ne feront pas partie du dispositif
pourront faire valoir qu'il y a là une
inégalité
merci jamais ensuite si vous voulez
compléter merci madame la Présidente
alors tout d'abord sur la distinction
entre dépénalisations ou légalisation
alors là c'est une distinction générale
en droit quand vous dépénalisez vous
faites en sorte qu'un comportement qui
était incriminable qui était susceptible
de justifier le fait que la personne qui
effectuait ce comportement pouvait être
atteinal n'était plus ne devient devient
libre au sens d'un principe général de
liberté en droit pénale qui fait que on
ne peut punir qu'à raison de ce qui a
été explicitement interdit dès lors que
vous
par une loi vous décidez que le code
pénal ne punit plus tel comportement ce
comportement rentre dans le champ
général des très nombreux comportements
qui relèvent du principe général de
liberté la légalisation qui peut
d'ailleurs croiser partiellement la
dépénalisation elle conduit à ce qu'une
loi explicitement autorise les individus
à agir d'une certaine manière avec tout
ce que permet une loi c'est-à-dire pas
uniquement prévoir que c'est désormais
autorisé mais aussi prévoir les
conditions dans lesquelles cela est
autorisé et donc lorsque vous
dépénalisez vous dites simplement ça
tombe dans le champ général d'un
principe de liberté lorsque vous
légalisez et bien vous pouvez fixer des
critères des conditions des procédures
en disant voilà ce qu'il faudra faire si
désormais vous souhaitez accéder à
l'assistance à un suicide assisté ou à
une euthanasie en ce qui concerne madame
la sénatrice les questions que vous
posiez sur certaines des plus grandes
notions du droit public et
constitutionnel notamment français la
liberté tout d'abord en l'occurrence
évidemment c'est très difficile de se
prononcer sur un texte sans même le
projet de loi qui va être le point de
départ peut-être de vos réflexions et de
vos travaux
le principe de liberté on peut
considérer que la liberté serait accrue
par l'ouverture faite aux individus de
d'accéder à ces fins de vie là
la dignité alors la dignité c'est
évidemment une question tout à fait
hypineuse c'est une catégorie juridique
dont les contours sont extrêmement
vagues dont la charge politique morale
est évidemment très importante et donc
le fait d'invoquer la dignité en
l'occurrence il me semble pas que il y
ait une solution toute prête que l'on
puisse déduire de ce principe de dignité
en effet on peut tout à fait invoquer la
dignité au soutien de l'idée selon
laquelle il faut permettre aux individus
de choisir les conditions dans
lesquelles il souhaite mourir en
particulier pour ceux qui sinon vont
subir des souffrances atroces avant la
fin naturelle ou normal c'est juste dire
sinon on ne fait rien des choses et puis
à l'inverse il y a ceux qui vont dire
mais c'est parfaitement indigne de
rendre possible le fait que l'État
autorise une manière ou d'une autre un
acte positif conduisant à la mort des
individus donc à cet égard je ne suis
pas certain que le principe de dignité
vous soit d'une il est incontournable
mais en même temps je suis pas sûr qu'il
vous souhaite une très grande aide en la
matière
à l'égalité alors je suis pas certain de
comprendre exactement les cas dans
lesquels
en fait c'était les conséquences
juridiques de légiférer au nom de la
liberté de choisir sa mort la
notion dignité mais j'ai bien compris et
de la légalité puisque ça a été évoqué
tout à l'heure alors
c'est les conséquences juridiques que
peuvent avoir sur l'égalité d'accès
le principe d'égalité en droit français
est un principe qui est tout à fait
malléable dans la mesure où en gros il
prévoit le fait que des personnes dans
des situations équivalentes doivent être
normalement traité de façon équivalente
et que des personnes dans les situations
différentes peuvent être traités de
manière différente dès lors que la
différence de traitement est en lien
avec la loi qui l'objectif de la loi qui
qui prévoit ce traitement dans les faits
lorsque l'on regarde la manière dont les
juges administratifs et constitutionnel
en particulier utilisent le principe
d'égalité on constate que il y a une
très grande malléabilité de ce de ce
principe qui dépend des paramètres
choisis selon vous vous concentrez sur
telle ou tel aspect et bien vous allez
considérer que les situations sont
analogues ou comparables ou à l'inverse
sont différentes et donc mérites ou
rendent possible la possibilité d'un
traitement différencié en l'occurrence
il faudrait voir ce dont on parle est-ce
que prendre par principe d'égalité on
entend le fait que serait traité
différemment des personnes qui
seraient en mesure d'exprimer de manière
consciente et répétée jusqu'au dernier
moment leur soin de mourir versus des
personnes qui seraient plus en mesure de
le faire et auxquels il faudrait se
fonder uniquement sur d'éventuelles
directives d'anticiper quid en l'absence
de directives anticipée on recroise des
questions qui sont bien connues des
spécialistes est-ce que le principe
d'égalité veut que simplement on
constate que en France des personnes en
général plus favorisées plus informés
savent que il est possible d'aller
mourir en Suisse au Luxembourg ou en
Belgique contrairement à des personnes
qui ne le savent pas ou qui n'ont pas
accès et qui se trouve à cet égard dans
une situation différente l'égalité à cet
égard me paraît ou être une ligne une
ligne de fond dans l'intégralité de vos
travaux quand je finis sur ce point un
touriste que de la pente glissante c'est
évidemment un argument plus politique
que juridique ma réponse de juriste
consiste à dire ou oui mais en même
temps vous êtes législateur c'est à dire
si vous décidez de dire on peut faire ça
vous n'êtes pas obligé de et c'est à
vous de faire en sorte l'argument a été
utilisé en 2013 à propos du mariage
ouvert aux personnes de même sexe il y a
eu beaucoup d'arguments de la pente
glissante bon ensuite le législateur a
pu faire évoluer le droit ponctuellement
sur des points précis mais c'était à
chaque fois en réfléchissant en sachant
pourquoi il y a donc l'idée selon
laquelle en bloquant une évolution on se
prémunirait contre le risque d'une
évolution néfaste ultérieure me semble
de toute façon une idée assez faible
dans la mesure où à tout instant
législateur dans 10 ans pourra avancer
avec un grand bon c'est chaud aussi si
le souhaite donc faites ce que vous
voulez faire un instant précis sans trop
vous poser la question des conséquences
intellectuelles idéologiques politiques
éventuelle de la loi que vous êtes en
train de préparer
[Musique]